hey hey according you are I sure hope
I'm in frame oh no you guys I know
you're disappointed
hey as it is Tuesday I'm it's great this
time to talk back to you let's start
over on tumblr her karate universe knew
pretty much probably they don't grow in
a new person comments on one of my
social media platforms I praise the crap
but on them I welcome them to the
degrees family I don't know if it's new
views are there no noise just guess and
what exactly is praising I just don't
know even but you'll feel something her
her ass more like her hard ass she
tripped backwards into it she is
literally a brick house keep it rise
they don't have this yeah what am I
saying
praise you you've been lace attorney
doesn't have any time for y'all [ __ ]
that photo the truth is we do have time
for your [ __ ] the other truth is that we
don't actually have any idea what time
it is ever what do you think to me use
your words
hell I'm helping new person to person a
person hella Helbig more like Bella
Helbig oh boy
literally man was that good yeah super
nice your grace I don't you know that if
you're too tired or busy and you can't
upload a video don't worry about it we
know you're busy with hey USA and other
various projects might be working on you
shouldn't have to stress out stress
about getting a video up for us if you
would rather not film on a signal to bed
early do it we would rather see you
well-rested than exhausted we care about
you sincerely made and I think most of
your viewers would agree that is so
sweet sleep sleep sleep sleep I'll think
about it now let's go to Twitter bihun
oh one to person to person to person B
huh no on is like the urban version of
c-3po that's how they talk hey I need
dream that gray Slovak name town and I
crashed a prom then had a karaoke party
in someone's front yard
seemed realistic to me
Tasha prom crashing the prom seems
really fun in theory but then you get
there and there's no open bars and just
a lot of awkward bodies sweating and
touching parts - music wasn't really
training new fridge maneuvers new purse
at one Holy Trinity more like one Holy
Trinity
he loves tacos thank you for uploading
and I hope you enjoy your day
what a charming comment
are you a charm bot this is making me
sad now let's go to your new globe that
was parking to person to person to
person Louis Parker more like whew is
Parker not Louis Parker because then I'd
be like give me the key I see I pretend
I'm a bush again it doesn't see me in
this hedge maze that went somewhere
Buick poor lace you are honestly the
best in person your grace not only did
you nail the celebrity but you
spectacularly impersonated a horse I am
speechless Wow thank you
Victoria wait nobody wears new person
Victoria wait wait wait
psych get the [ __ ] out of here Milo's I
crushed all the chips oh no I knew it
when they were already in the air I was
disappointed by this to be honest thank
you for the constructive criticism more
like construction criticism because that
comment really came in
everyone but there you go that's it for
talking back to you make sure you're
still filming cuz I just don't trust you
I trust you now cuz you are I'll never
do it again except just one more time oh
my god
let's ever talk you back to you today I
hope that you enjoyed this time than
we've spent together I don't know ah
don't even want to see if the chips are
okay Oh a lot of men down oh you're fine
hold on what's up